here's the problem we forget that no
one's politically correct up here we're
all animals we're all trying to we're
all seeing the same thing we're all
thinking the same thing no one's PC in
their brain that's just a filter you put
on when you talk so you seem nice like
no one sees a hot girl bend over and
thinks look at that independent woman
like to treat her equally
ah we're sick men and women we're gross
but look where it's all gotten us then I
feel like the whole country's pent up
feels everybody's angry right now we got
white supremacists protests hate groups
it's weird you're allowed to be hateful
in America as long as you're not
specific isn't that weird and if you're
like I hate Mexican people everybody's
like oh my God what a bigot Prejudice
but if you're like I hate people
everybody's like huh right
isn't that worse people are angry now
man I had one of those uh White lives
matter rallies go by my house the other
day I freaked out then I realized oh
it's just a half marathon
that was close
I don't know just be a good person what
about that just be nice to people you
know